guten Tag Frau Mohammed Ali
guten Tag
gestern kam der Brief zu ihrem Rückzug
wie geht es Ihnen heute damit und hätte
man sie vielleicht noch vorher umstimmen
können
also mir geht es heute gut ich bin froh
dass das ausgesprochen ist und es war
für mich ja eine eine Entscheidung die
von meiner Überzeugung getragen war
deswegen geht mir das heute gut damit
sie sind sich aber schon bewusst dass
dieser Rückzug so etwas wie der
Sargnagel für ihre Partei werden könnte
denn wenn sie gehen wenn noch andere
gehen dann verliert die Partei ihren
fraktions- ihren Fraktionsstatus und
ohne hin geht es der Partei ja mit rund
ich muss mal gerade noch mal gucken vier
Prozent hat sie jetzt im in den neuesten
Umfragen nicht gut
ich habe mich ja nicht aus der Partei
zurückgezogen sondern ich habe erklärt
dass ich nicht noch einmal für den
Fraktionsvorsitz kandidieren werde weil
es eben auch dazu zur Aufgabe einer Frau
sonstigen gehört dazu Personen
herausgehobenen Positionen ja die Partei
die Linie der Parteivorsitzenden zu
vertreten und das ist mir immer weniger
möglich gewesen ist mit zum Schluss eben
unmöglich gewesen deswegen war es von
mir nur konsequent das jetzt so zu
erklären ich habe aber die Parteien
nicht verlassen ich habe nur gesagt dass
ich nicht wieder kandidiere sie haben
die Parteien nicht verlassen aber das
ist ja ein schwerer Brocken den sie da
ihrer Partei vor die Füße geworfen haben
jemand der nicht mehr antritt und der so
Unzufriedenheit äußert wie sie das ist
ja nicht einfach für eine Partei zu
verkraften
ja es ist aber so dass ich natürlich
meinem Gewissen verantwortlich bin und
eben zu meinen Überzeugung stehe und ich
bin zum Ergebnis gekommen dass ich den
Kurs der Parteiführung die eben kein
klares Jahr mehr sagen kann
zufriedenspolitik die ist nicht schafft
die wie ich finde falsche Politik der
Ampelkoalition ganz klar zu verurteilen
und klar macht wofür der ja welche für
wen sie eigentlich Politik machen möchte
nämlich für die Mehrheit der Menschen in
diesem Land dass ich sage das ist ein
Kurs den ich immer mittragen kann das
ist keine neue Information dass ich
diese Haltung habe ich habe meine
Haltung also nicht geändert ich bin in
die Politik gegangen und stehe dafür
bestimmte Inhalte für die stehe ich nach
wie vor und das deckt sich an den
Stellen die ich genannt habe eben nicht
mehr mit dem Kurs der Parteiführung und
ja die Schlussfolgerung daraus müssen
vielleicht andere ziehen
es wird ja jetzt auch so interpretiert
als seien sie aus Loyalität zu Sarah
Wagenknecht zurück zu treten
zurückgetreten was sagen sie dazu
ich war wirklich Ausbruch und zufrieden
mit dem beschluss des Parteivorstandes
in dem öffentlich verkündet worden ist
dass die Zukunft der Linken eine Zukunft
ohne Sahra Wagenknecht sei und sie auch
noch aufgefordert wird sie und auch
andere jemand raten die dazu legen und
ich finde das inakzeptabel dass man da
ist frei da steht so in unserem
Grundgesetz und ich finde das nicht
akzeptabel dass die parteivor so eine
Entscheidung gefällt hat leider muss ich
feststellen dass auch sehr viele
Landesverbände sich diese Entscheidung
zu eigen gemacht haben und auch das war
für mich auch Schlag geben dafür dann
die Konsequenz zu ziehen und zu sagen
dann stehe ich für ein so ist so hohes
Amt und jetzigen Zeitpunkt nicht mehr
zur Verfügung kann man vielleicht aber
auch die andere Seite verstehen also der
parteifize göster Beutin hat heute
gesagt das sei eine rote Linie
überschritten wenn man die Existenz der
Partei in Frage stelle wie es Frau
Wagenknecht ja zum Beispiel getan hat
ich teile diese Sichtweise nicht weil
ich verstehe nicht in wo wo Sahra
wahnsinnig die Existenz der Linken in
Frage gestellt hat die Linke in einer
Partei vielleicht eine neue Partei
Gründe das hat gesagt dass sie bestimmte
Positionen nicht teilt und sie hat auch
gesagt dass sie überlegt in Zukunft
etwas anderes zu machen also damit wird
die Existenz der Parteien nicht in Frage
gestellt und ich finde es einfach einer
Partei die sich Pluralität auf die
Fahnen geschrieben hat in der
Solidarität eigentlich mal wichtige
Werte waren finde ich ist unangemessen
dann in Öffentlichkeit sich von sag mal
auch ihre prominentesten Person wurde
distanzieren zu müssen ich finde das
einfach falsch
sie stehen vor wichtigen Wahlen äh die
Politik Deutschland steht vor wichtigen
Wahlen auch im Osten wenn sie mal mit
mir gemeinsam in die Zukunft blicken ähm
was glauben sie gibt wird sie linke noch
geben in anderthalb Jahren sage ich mal
in einem Jahr
wir wissen nicht was die Zukunft bringt
was ich mir aber von Herzen wünsche ist
dass es eine politische Kraft in
Deutschland gibt die sich konsequent
einsetzt für die Belange der großen
Mehrheit der Bevölkerung die halt von
der aktuellen Regierungspolitik leider
vergessen wird wir erleben ist dass
die Ampelkoalition viele Menschen im
Stich lässt das Armut sich vergrößert
dass der Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland
gefährdet ist durch einmal durch die wie
ich finde falsche fraktionspolitik aber
eben auch dadurch dass überhaupt keine
vernünftige Wirtschaftsförderung
stattfindet und viele viele andere Dinge
und hier bräuchte es dringend eine sehr
laute Stimme für die Mehrheit der
Bevölkerung für Interessen auf der
Arbeitnehmer Bevölkerung diese Stimme
ist meiner Erfahrung für mich lange Zeit
die Linke im Moment sehe ich das nicht
mehr aber ich hoffe und wünsche dass es
so eine Kraft gibt weil ich halt für
dringend
Amira Mohammed Ali war das die ihren
Rückzug aus einem führenden Abend in der
Linken angekündigt hat gestern
herzlichen Dank